Вітаю А це справді один із кроків Бо
коли Україна отримала томос коли постала
фрикефальна незалежна визина
православним світом православна церква
України цей день став якраз може справою
часу і дуже добре що він Нарешті настав
чекаємо щось справді українське святиня
яке його Печерська лавра буде позбавлена
Московського впливу і переконаний що так
само має відбутися з іншими українськими
світиннями історичними церквами які є по
всій країні Там має звучати молитву
українською мовою а там має бути
український дух Бо коли команда
Порошенка якраз працювала і Порошенко як
президента куди всіх зусиль щоб Україна
отримала томос і отримала свою церкву
якраз передбачалося що рано чи пізно всі
українські церкви мають бути власне в
православній церквізії ми тут бачимо
також дуже цікаву таку табличку про те
скільки кілометрів до Москви бачимо що
до Ростова ближче геть ворожу церкву
розкажіть трошки детальніше очевидно що
всі ті прихожани які зараз і московські
купи також їх зараз прийшли сюди на свої
останні богослужіння в лавру вони бачать
цей плакат вони також бачимо що вони
фотографують його ну власне в цьому ідея
ми зараз знаходимося якраз навпроти
головного входу в нижній печери в так
званого нижню лавру ми бачимо як
автобусами привозять цих прихожан Ну я
думаю що їм корисно знати як е-е як їм
бути Куди її мети Як ваші колеги
запитала як Теж їм потім власне себе
знайти Ну в принципі є пояснення де саме
і куди Ну і наостанок як думаєте чи
будуть вони все ж таки намагатися
утриматися за свої храми у лаврі чи
будуть намагатися судитися далі Ну я
думаю що це для держави і для влади
зараз дуже серйозний іспит тому що
зроблено дуже серйозний крок і просто
бачите вірити і бути впевненим що він
був підготовлений і ми нематовим якимось
неприємних сюрпризів Ви поки що ми чуємо
запевнення що це буде відповідно до
закону ззаду залишилася кілька годин
побачив як це буде чого Донбас постав От
того що їх Янукович давайте Януковичі
обманув так Донбас Донбас не поставив
Донбас зайшли росіяни які не вдалося
купували
перше перше бомбили українці
ніякі не треба задавати розказувати до
вас не хотів Порошенку тож не хотів
Майдан Це правда
що що Майдан доброго удав в Україні Що
доброго Майдан Да в Україні я був
Україна вибрала свій шлях на Майдані до
Європейського Союзу
ніякої Європи не буде запам'ятайте